at home with Simon Cowell's golden
buzzer plus more on the death of Anthony
Bourdain I'm gonna say it guys what an
awful week I promise I have a
light-hearted feel-good story coming up
but first and I can't believe this is
the second story of this kind of talking
about this week but full of food critic
and chef Anthony Bourdain was found dead
today of an apparent suicide the 61 year
old was found in his hotel room in
eastern France he was there filming an
episode for the next season of CNN's
parts unknown the network tells ET their
thoughts and prayers are with his 11
year old daughter and the rest of his
family at this time
Bourdain also leaves behind girlfriend
Asia Argento who wrote he was my love my
rock my protector
I am beyond devastated of course so many
fans and celebrity friends of Bourdain's
have been paying their respects Chrissy
Teigen called Anthony one of her idols
unapologetic passionate and one of the
best storytellers she even opened up
about her own bouts with depression and
something she tweeted ring with me that
I want to tell you guys right now
watch the people you love and don't be
afraid to speak up I had the pleasure of
chatting with Anthony Bourdain myself
backstage after he won his fourth
consecutive Emmy and it was such an
awesome moment for me because he was
brass but genuine and I remember
thinking okay I need have a drink with
this guy you'll understand why take a
look how you celebrating tonight bass
drunk with a big bag in-n-out burgers
Toby your vices in it now you're gonna
go ham on a double-double aren't you I'm
gonna buy a disgusting number of
double-double animal style I Mike over
the animal fries I'm definitely doing
the shake you know maybe I'll put like
peppermint schnapps in the shake or
something like that just go totally
nasty you know what you deserve you
deserve it you earned it you got an Emmy
thank you congratulations the man loved
his in and out I gotta say what a loss
don't take the people in your life for
granted guys but also don't take
yourself for granted The Suicide
Prevention lifeline is there and don't
even hesitate to check up on even your
strongest friend
all right guys but switching gears to a
truly beautiful story that I think we
could all use right now you guys
remember Michael Ketterer he's the
father of six who won Oh
Simon Cowell with his story and his
voice on America's Got Talent
well the golden buzzer singer said he
wanted to inspire his kids and he did
just that and only I got a special
invite to their home I mean what was
going on in your head when he hit that
button it was like I went from being
that place of nervous to just pure joy
and just being overwhelmed when he hit
that buzzer it was one of the greatest
feelings I've ever felt long before
marrying his high school sweetheart ivy
America's Got Talent contestant
pediatric nurse michael Ketterer grew up
singing in church you start realizing
other things that kind of mean more to
you than even your your greatest dreams
and I think to me it was being able to
adopt these children and being able to
impact the lives of children not spin
you around okay I think we're the best
team I can tell yeah I couldn't do it
without her Michael and Ivy decided to
pursue adoption when their daughter
Sophie was six and asked for brothers
the couple went on to adopt five boys
from foster care starting with brothers
Jared Chase had your eye next came Sean
who at one point was homeless on the
streets did you guys have fun being up
backstage at America's Got Talent and
meeting Tyra Banks she's so pretty right
then a call they never expected to get
meet Rodrigo affectionately known as
rowdy Ron it's your turn you're up man
the nine-year-old suffers from cerebral
palsy and despite his bright smile rowdy
never was able to communicate until he
met his new family when we first got him
he he couldn't talk because he was
shaking infants so he was abused by his
caregiver and that's what what gave him
cerebral palsy prior to that he was
totally moved but once we got him
because he couldn't speak
he loved to hear the music and he loved
to feel the rhythms of the music so yeah
so I would spend a lot of my time with
him communicating basically with him
through song
[Music]
[Applause]
he's amazing and watching Mike in his
kids playing in the backyard I was like
is this an episode of this is us I can't
so beautiful the next time we'll get to
hear Michael's scene is when the live
show start on August 14th
now speaking of singers it is new music
Friday and let's kick things off with
Troye Sivan who dropped his music video
for bloom this week
[Music]
just for
[Music]
[Music]
this kid this guy is big a pop star we
needed do you Troy
which brings me to another huge LGBTQ
advocate miss Christina Aguilera
her sixth album liberation is out June
15th but gave us another taste of the
record with her latest single featuring
goldlink like I do
[Music]
[Music]
okay come through with that one
Christina
and finally Shakira and maluma teamed up
again for another firecloud and I
guarantee you'll be swinging your hips
to clandestino
[Music]
those two are so pretty it hurts all
right guys well before I sign off
there's another duo making waves and
that's Josh Groban and Sara Bareilles
they'll be hosting this Sunday's Tony
Awards live on CBS and CBS all access
and guess what your boy is hosting the
official red carpet pre-show live on
Facebook watch at 2 p.m. Pacific 5 p.m.
Eastern which by the way means I will be
in New York and won't be here Monday but
my pal ash crossing will be here to fill
in so enjoy your weekend does and I'll
see you on Broadway dan dan dan
[Music]